SIERRA: Nuclear energy.
Back to the Future: Are you telling me that
this sucker is nuclear?
No, no, no, no, no, this sucker is electrical.
I need a nuclear reaction to generate the
1.21 gigawatts of electricity I need.
The Simpsons: Watch out, Radioactive Man!
Justice League Unlimited: There s a breach
in the reactor room. We are getting radiation
alarms from several lower floors.
Young Sheldon: It s clean and efficient and
very safe, until something goes horribly wrong.
The Simpsons: It s the job of tomorrow, today!
SIERRA: A lot of our ideas about nuclear energy
come from what we have seen on the big screen
or on TV. Mutants, supervillains, and time-traveling
cars, sure, but also the haunting legacies
of real-life disasters. Nuclear is just unsettling.
After all, no other energy source leaves behind
radioactive waste that lasts for tens of thousands
of years. But nuclear energy is also widely
misunderstood. And as the climate crisis accelerates,
many experts believe that it may be one of
the best tools we have for eliminating our
dependence on fossil fuels. I m Gabrielle
Sierra, and this is Why It Matters, today,
the truth about nuclear energy in the era
of climate change.
Reuters: Representatives from nearly 200 countries
will convene in Glasgow, Scotland at the end
of October for the COP26 conference to strengthen
action against global warming.
Greenpeace USA: No! Nukes! No! Nukes!
KPBS: So, what s your biggest fear? A meltdown,
a spent fuel fire, sabotage, tsunami, earthquake,
man-made error, human mistakes, engineering
mistakes, not sure which one s biggest.
Forbes Breaking News: Nuclear energy, it s
a non-green house gas power generation source
and a crucial tool in the battle against climate
change.
SIERRA: All right, well, I mean let's talk
about the big question. What role is nuclear
energy currently playing in the battle against
climate change? And what role do you think
it should play?
DEWAN: It's my belief that nuclear is crucial
for moving the world away from fossil fuels.
DEWAN: I'm Leslie Dewan. I'm a nuclear engineer
and I run a radiation detection company called
RadiantNano. And I became a nuclear engineer
in the first place, because I've always been
an environmentalist. Right now, nuclear is
doing a lot of the heavy lifting. So between
about a half and two thirds of the carbon
free electricity in the US comes from nuclear,
somewhat similar numbers worldwide.
SIERRA: So let s put this into perspective
a bit. In 2020, fossil fuels generated about
60 percent of the electricity in the United
States. Nuclear accounted for roughly 20 percent,
that s about the same as solar, wind, and
all other renewables combined. Now it s important
to understand that electricity production
is only part of the overall carbon picture,
but it is a big part. In 2019, electricity
production accounted for about a quarter of
all global carbon emissions. Even if the world
got that down to zero, there would still be
emissions from cars, the shipping industry,
and many other sources. But why use nuclear
power at all? Why not stick to safer options
like wind, and solar?
DEWAN: So the big advantage of nuclear is
the base load energy supply. Basically, it
can produce a constant amount of power without
needing to store electricity in battery backups.
So I'm 100% in favor of expanding the amount
of solar and wind that we're using, but the
tricky thing with wind especially is that
you can have days when you have a lot of wind
and there's a large oversupply of electricity,
and you need to find a way to store it. Or
you can have days where there isn't any wind
at all and you need to find a way to make
up for that shortfall. So nuclear is very,
very good at basically helping to smooth out
those peaks and troughs in supply.
JACKSON: We are all, I think, more interested
today in having as low a carbon footprint
in our activities as we can.
SIERRA: This is Dr. Shirley Ann Jackson. She
is the president of the Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute, and Institute professor of physics,
applied physics and astronomy, as well as
a professor of engineering sciences. In 1995
Dr. Jackson was appointed by President Clinton
to run the US Nuclear Regulatory commission,
meaning that she was the chief authority on
nuclear safety in the United States. She has
been a global leader in the effort to advance
and safely regulate nuclear power for decades.
JACKSON: And obviously power generation is
important for maintaining societies and uplifting
lives. And so we have to work out a plan based
on all possible energy solutions, and with
the high energy density, it's reliability
when well-managed, and the low carbon footprint
of nuclear plants, I think we have to think
about nuclear energy as part of an overall
strategy. And that is why it should matter
to us.
SIERRA: How safe is nuclear energy?
JACKSON: Well, what people worry about is
exposure. People think about radiation. They
think maybe when they see vapor that really
comes from cooling towers at a nuclear plant,
they're thinking that it's a radioactive release,
it is not. Some fear that there might be a
release in wastewater coming from the plant.
And there are myriad systems that are built
in to keep that from happening. People are
not just willy-nilly operating things in an
unsafe manner. And so that, I believe, should
help to allay people's fears.
The safeguard systems that Dr. Jackson referenced
do a very good job of preventing nuclear disasters
in the United States. That said, 49 percent
of Americans oppose nuclear energy and only
47 percent of Americans believe nuclear power
is safe. Part of the problem is that most
of us don t understand what s happening inside
those plants.
SIERRA: Can you give me a 101 on the science
of how nuclear energy works?
DEWAN: Nuclear energy is basically just a
fancy way of boiling water. So within a nuclear
reactor core, you have your uranium oxide
fuel rods, they're cooled and moderated by
liquid water. And the fuel rods are in a configuration
where they've achieved what's called criticality.
So they have a large stable number of nuclear
fission reactions that are generating a great
deal of heat. That heat is carried away by
the water flowing past them, boils the water
up into steam, the steam drives the turbine
that turns the generator that produces electricity.
SIERRA: Nuclear fission is the process by
which atoms split, creating enormous amounts
of energy. Nuclear reactors are basically
just structures that are able to control this
process in a safe and useful way. But not
all reactors are the same.
SIERRA: So let's talk about reactors. What
do they do and are there different types?
DEWAN: So the majority of nuclear reactors
operating today are what's called light water
reactors. They re sometimes called conventional
reactors or traditional reactors. These reactors
are actually not first developed for power
production, not for really producing electricity,
they were actually first developed in the
1950s for nuclear powered submarines. So they
came out of the US Navy initially. And then
it wasn't until around 1956 at the height
of the Cold War when the US said, all right,
we want to have nuclear reactors used for
power on land. And as a point of national
pride, we want to get these up and running
as quickly as possible. We want to get this
done specifically before the Soviet Union
does. And so they took these submarine based
reactors and put them on land. And that means
that there's a lot of room for improvement.
And so that's what the next generation of
reactors, the so-called advanced reactors,
are trying to adapt to, trying to basically
make nuclear reactors that are impeccably
well suited for use on land. And there are
a few different varieties of these advanced
reactors. So the one closest to my heart is
called a molten salt reactor that uses liquid
fuel rather than solid fuel. There are also
reactors that use uranium metal as fuel and
they're cooled and moderated by either liquid
sodium or liquid lead. Those are called metal
fast reactors. And then there are reactors
cooled by gas, reactors that use, instead,
fuel rods, pebbles of fuel. And they all have
different safety benefits and some of their
own new drawbacks as well. But overall, the
hope is that these new reactors will be much
more lower cost, more proliferation resistant
and easier to roll out and higher efficiency
as well.
SIERRA: I love that you described a reactor
as being close to your heart.
SIERRA: These new reactors are designed to
address the weak points of nuclear energy.
And there are weak points. The problems fall
into four basic buckets: cost, waste, security,
and the rare but serious possibility of disaster.
WNEP: An unexpected release of more radiation
today from the Three Mile Island nuclear power
plant has led to a series of consequences.
ABC News In-depth: Massive quantities of radiation
have apparently been released at an accident
at the Chernobyl power station in the Ukraine.
TODAY: Fukushima. It began with the strongest
earthquake in Japan s history, one of the
world s worst nuclear disasters.
DEWAN: I think that s something that the nuclear
industry needs to be really, really open about,
talking about what went wrong in those accidents,
talking about how the existing nuclear facilities
are different from that previous generation
of plants. So what went wrong in all three
of those cases in Three Mile Island, Chernobyl
and Fukushima is basically those plants lost
their electricity and then lost the cooling
water that went over the uranium oxide fuel
rods. So lost electricity to the pumps, the
pumps the cooling water, cooling water drained
away. And then your uranium oxide fuel rods
would heat up and heat up and heat up with
nothing to cool them down. And eventually
they heated up so much that the structural
integrity of the fuel rods was compromised.
They started to bend, they started to melt.
And that's what a nuclear meltdown is. The
newer generation of nuclear reactors have
very, very different cooling requirements.
And so in many cases, it's just not possible
for them to have a meltdown, like in the case
of a molten salt reactor. And so I think that's
an important piece to get across is that the
technology of these advanced reactors is so
different that it really obviates some of
the prior failure modes that were there.
SIERRA: Meltdowns are terrifying and tragic,
but it would be a big mistake to think that
nuclear is the most deadly power source. A
recent Harvard study found that air pollution
from fossil fuel combustion was responsible
for 8.7 million deaths globally in 2018 alone.
By comparison, nuclear power has caused about
5,000 deaths in a 38 year period from 1971-2009.
Deaths from nuclear power are typically caused
by onsite accidents, whereas deaths from fossil
fuels are largely caused by the air pollution
they create. Exact comparisons are difficult,
but the difference in scale is obvious.
JACKSON: Well, I actually visited Chernobyl
in my first year as chairman of the NRC, and
that does focus the mind. And I actually visited
the site, and I had to wear every dosimeter
known to man or woman. Both ones that would
measure longer term exposure over the time
I was there, as well as what are called alarming
dosimeters if things start to get hot on the
spot. And then I had to go to NIH before I
left for a whole body scan, and another one
when I got back. But I felt it was important
to understand what countries were dealing
with, in this case Ukraine. Any technology
sits on a knife edge, and there can be sometimes
accidents or sometimes things may be deliberately
used for ill. But on average, nuclear is much
more regulated, and has much more oversight
than your typical fossil generating station
or your typical chemical plant that people
deal with every day. And so I would not, as
a former chairman of the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission, tell you that one can just operate
these facilities willy-nilly. But at the same
time, I would say you have to ask yourself
as you look over a time, how much has happened
because of a nuclear accident compared to
chemical plant accidents and the like.
SIERRA: So the idea sounds like if you do
it safely, and the right precautions are put
in place, the right oversight, there shouldn't
be this impulse of not in my backyard. It
should be a pretty safe thing to have around
a town.
JACKSON: I would say so, but citizens have
the right to demand that there be that appropriate
oversight, and that there be transparency
about that oversight. And I always, as chair,
felt that that was my responsibility, and
talking with people. So whenever I visited
a nuclear power plant, I also met with the
local population as well as having a press
conference even if there was nothing in particular
to talk about, but it was important to answer
people's questions.
SIERRA: Disasters are rare, but there s another
problem that will always be part of the nuclear
equation. Radioactive waste. Nuclear reactors
use radioactive material like uranium for
fuel. The problem is that once the process
is finished, there s still a lot of radioactive
stuff leftover, stuff that will remain deadly
for tens of thousands of years. So the question
becomes one of figuring out how to store this
material as safely as possible. In the United
States, spent fuel from nuclear power plants
is put into rods and stored in cooling pools
at or near the site itself. But these sites
are considered temporary. Scientists agree
that the most promising long-term solution
is to store radioactive materials deep underground,
and there have been plans to develop such
a facility at Yucca Mountain, Nevada for decades.
But so far it has not been politically feasible.
JACKSON: There are really two kinds of nuclear
waste that people think about the most. One
is what's called low level waste. And that's
waste that where the radioactivity is low,
and where the disposal is easier, and can
be disposed of in fairly shallow types of
repositories. The problem comes with high
level waste, and spent fuel is the type that
one thinks about. And the fuel comes in the
form of rods. And these spent fuel rods are
very highly radioactive. They have very long
live radioactivity and they generate a lot
of heat. And so they require very careful
handling over a very long period. And so we
actually have about 70,000 metric tons of
spent fuel around the country. And about 2000
metric tons are generated every year. And
by 2055, the belief is we'll have about twice
as much. And this is spread around at 75 different
operating and decommissioned nuclear plants
all across the United States. And worldwide,
I think the estimate is about 300,000 a metric
tons. But to this point, all efforts to create
a permanent deep geologic repository have
failed.
DEWAN: There are some nuclear reactors today,
like some of the ones that are operating in
France that do what's called reprocessing
spent nuclear fuel. So you take the spent
fuel that's coming out of a reactor, deconstruct
it, repartition it, put it into new nuclear
fuel assemblies and you're able to extract
some additional energy from it, say, another
three or four or five percent of the energy
that you could potentially get out of the
uranium. There are some other companies and
research groups today that are working on
making that much better, being able to extract
even more of the energy out of the spent nuclear
fuel, so you're leaving behind less waste
in turn. But that problem is definitely not
solved yet. And even with those reprocessing
facilities, there's still waste coming out
of the backend of the design. And so people
are figuring out better ways to store that
in the long term, because this is waste that
you need to keep a handle on for on the order
of 10,000 years. So it's very much a geological
timescale problem.
SIERRA: Dealing with radioactive waste is
tricky and dangerous. It s also expensive.
And advanced safety protocols are only part
of the reason that nuclear power plants are
a costly investment. There s also all the
materials and technology that go into building
the facility, and then the operational and
maintenance costs required to keep it running
under a strict regulatory system.
DEWAN: The expensive nuclear is, to my mind,
one of the biggest aspects that's holding
back the construction of more nuclear power
plants. Some of the reactors that are being
built today in the US and Western Europe have
very, very significant cost overruns. And
these are plants that would have been, you
know, their initial estimates were still very
expensive. You have a plant that was initially
expected to cost $7 or $8 billion, it ends
up costing $13 billion. And that's just not
sustainable. And so I think this isn't the
most glamorous part of engineering, but I
think there's so much potential for just streamlining
the construction process, making more modular
nuclear reactors. There's a whole category
called small modular nuclear reactors where
in general, you'd be producing all of the
components at a central location and then
shipping out the reactors to where they're
ultimately going to be installed. And I think
that decreasing that overall cost, increasing
modularity while still keeping the same safety
benefits, I think will be crucial to building
more nuclear worldwide.
SIERRA: The last issue with nuclear power
doesn t have to do with the technology itself,
but with the possibility that it could be
attacked, stolen, or exploited by adversaries.
SIERRA: What type of terrorism risks do nuclear
power plants present? Can someone hack them
and cause a disaster?
JACKSON: Well, what ends up happening with
most nuclear plants frankly, is that the nuclear
plants don't tend to be directly connected
to the internet. And so that's not to say
that one, people don't think about how they
might reach into a plant because nefarious
actors will always do that, but the plants
are designed to not be so easily accessible,
and it's not something that is discussed publicly.
Secondly, the plants do have controls which
tend to shut them down very quickly if, in
fact, there is some irregularity. And so that's
all I would really say about that.
SIERRA: But a direct attack on a nuclear plant,
whether cyber or traditional, is not the only
security fear.
DEWAN: So what you need to be really careful
about is monitoring the nuclear material that's
going into the plant in the form of fuel rods
or any other type of fuel form rather, and
then also tracking the material that's leaving
the plant. So when you take out your spent
fuel rods from the reactor and put them in
a spent fuel pool to cool them down or put
them into dry cask storage on the site after
you've extracted the energy that you can extract
from the fuel. So it wouldn't practically
speaking be possible to take that spent fuel
or that fresh fuel and turn it into a full
fledged nuclear bomb, but it is radioactive
material. And so you need to make sure that
people aren't diverting that and turning that
into a dirty bomb, for example. So you do
have to have very, very strict security and
safeguards protocols to monitor where that
is at any one time.
SIERRA: So let's talk a bit about the connection
between nuclear energy and nuclear weapons.
What's the connection? Is there a connection?
And where do we see a potential problem playing
out?
DEWAN: Looking at it from an engineering perspective,
so the nuclear material that goes into weapons
is very different from the nuclear material
that's used in power facilities. And if you
are making a nuclear weapon that nuclear material
has to have greater than 90% or typically
greater than 95% uranium-235 for it to be
feasible to be used in a bomb. In nuclear
power facilities, it's approximately 5% uranium-235.
So you couldn't take the uranium from a nuclear
reactor and turn that into a nuclear bomb.
It just would not be physically possible.
JACKSON: In order to get to that, it requires
additional capability in terms of the ability
to actually do that enrichment. And that takes
a lot of infrastructure, money, focus, and
time. But of course, then what gets monitored
by the organizations like the IAEA is just
that whether they are facilities, be they,
most of the time, clandestine that a country
may have where it's looking to create weapons-grade,
uranium, or plutonium. And so those are the
things that people spend a lot of time focusing
on being able to detect.
SIERRA: Sure. So the concern is that a nuclear
power program could be a cover for a nuclear
weapons program?
JACKSON: Well, that is something that, of
course, a nation would worry about, that a
country like ours would worry about. That's
why people worry about centrifuges in certain
countries, and how many stages to the centrifuges
there are because those things link to how
much uranium can be enriched, and enriched
to the point that it becomes what's called
weapons-grade. I mean, these are very sensitive
issues as you can imagine.
SIERRA: This concern isn t hypothetical. Take
Iran for example. Their nuclear energy program
began in 1957, with the help of President
Eisenhower s Atoms for Peace program. Many
believe this initiative set the foundation
for Iran to secretly develop a nuclear weapons
program by providing dual-use technology,
equipment, and education. It s just one example
of how nuclear technology is never a trivial
matter. And why it requires such strict regulation.
DEWAN: So the majority of nuclear plants in
the US are run by private energy utilities.
For example, Southern Company owns and operates
the vast majority of plants within the southeastern
United States. But throughout it, there's
a very, very strong government oversight process,
throughout basically every stage of the plant
from the early design to pouring the concrete
to operating the facility. And that oversight
is almost entirely done by the U.S. Nuclear
Regulatory Commission at basically all stages.
SIERRA: Is there oversight of nuclear power
at the global level?
JACKSON: Oh, sure. Well, how does that occur?
I mean, it emanates from, in our case, from
the national to the global. And let me explain
that. There's a layered effect. So there are
laws in this country that govern that regulatory
oversight. They began with the Atomic Energy
Act which has been in existence for 70, 80
years, but it's also governed by the various
environmental acts, the NRC policy acts, the
Nuclear Waste Policy Act, and what's called
The Energy Reorganization Act of 1974 that
created the NRC. But then that plays against
a larger background that links to bilateral
agreements between countries as well as work
through multi national organizations. And
what are they? The one that most people hear
about is the IAEA, the International Atomic
Energy Agency.
SIERRA: This organization was created to promote
the peaceful use of nuclear energy, and to
prevent it from being used for military purposes.
It s a forum for cooperation on peaceful nuclear
technology, but it s also a watchdog that
has the authority to conduct inspections of
nuclear facilities to ensure that they are
safe, and that they are not being used to
develop nuclear weapons. The IAEA derives
its authority from the Treaty on the Non-Proliferation
of Nuclear Weapons, an agreement between 191
countries, that aims to prevent the spread
of nuclear weapons.
JACKSON: So there, any number of international
agreements that provide an overall safety
envelope. In addition, there are international
agreements and treaties that relate to nuclear
weapons as well. And all of those are meant
to provide a framework that ensures that there's
the highest level of focus and adherence to
nuclear safety, and what I call nuclear safeguards.
And so these are things that play what happens
at the national level into what happens at
the international level.
SIERRA: Does the need for regulation and safety
increase the end cost of nuclear energy?
DEWAN: It does increase the end cost, but
it's crucially necessary. Like, I think that
if there's any field at all whatsoever that
should be regulatory heavy, nuclear is certainly
it. So I view all of those regulations as
being just an integral part of the process.
And along the lines of regulation, I think
that the US Nuclear Regulatory Commission
has become very, very forward looking when
it comes to thinking about, say, how you regulate
the next generation of nuclear reactors. And
so it's been really, really interesting to
me and it's a very, very welcome change that
they're starting to embrace, like what do
these new designs look like.
SIERRA: As some scientists work to refine
traditional nuclear technology, others are
working on a moonshot breakthrough that could
change everything we know about energy. It
s called nuclear fusion, and it s the same
process that has powered the sun for billions
of years. If we can replicate this reaction
on earth, it would generate virtually an unlimited
supply of energy, with no radioactive waste
and no greenhouse gas emissions. Scientists
around the world believe fusion is the energy
for the future. But safe and limitless energy
is no easy feat.
DEWAN: The
joke is that fusion is 30 years away and always
will be. But if it works and there actually
has been a lot of really interesting progress
on that front, just over the past few years,
it would be able to provide large amounts
of electricity and much more cleanly than
nuclear fission. The tricky thing is there
are a lot of scientific unknowns and a lot
of engineering unknowns. And then after you
lock those down, you still need to deal with
how you construct these plants in an economical
fashion. So there's a lot of work still to
be done, but there are some really brilliant
people and even some just fascinating private
companies that are making really great strides
on developing commercially viable fusion plants
for the future.
SIERRA: Fusion would represent an unparalleled
breakthrough in the fight against climate
change. But it may still be a long ways off.
For now, countries have to weigh mounting
climate and energy pressures against the expense
and stigma of existing nuclear technology.
Some countries, like Australia for example,
have no nuclear power at all. At the other
end of the spectrum you have countries like
the UK, which plans to center nuclear to achieve
a fossil-fuel free energy grid by 2035. China
is planning a 40% increase in nuclear capacity.
India has 7 new plants under construction.
And France is setting aside 1 billion Euros
for small modular reactors.
DEWAN: So France in particular has a very
high fraction of their electricity coming
from nuclear. I think right now it's about
80%. In the past it was slightly higher. Yeah.
And so France among every industrial country
has by far the lowest greenhouse gas production,
because so much of their energy comes from
nuclear. And France in particular when they
were building a lot of these reactors in the
1970s were especially good about streamlining
the construction process as well. They built
very, very similar reactor units across the
country, which allowed them to cookie cutter
style, just roll them out one after another,
after another. And just streamlining the actual
construction is one of the most crucial pieces
for making sure that these plants can be built
on time and on budget.
SIERRA: So where is the United States in all
of this? We still derive about 20 percent
of our electricity from nuclear power, but
the infrastructure is aging. 12 reactors were
permanently closed between 2013 and 2021,
and in many cases this led to an increased
use of fossil fuels. If these trends continue,
the nuclear share of U.S. electricity generation
could fall to just 11 percent by 2050.
SIERRA: What is the risk if we don't pursue
further research and implementation of nuclear
energy?
DEWAN: I think that nuclear is crucial for
hitting our climate goals. I think there's
no way that we'll be able to hit our climate
goals with solar and wind and hydro and geothermal
alone. To get a little bit more specific on
that, there aren't very many more places in
the world where we can install additional
hydro or geothermal and wind and solar. They're
fantastic technologies, but we need to couple
them with better grid scale energy storage
or else they won't be useful for the grid.
One of the craziest things to me about the
electric grid in general as a system is that
you need to across an electric grid match
very, very closely the amount of electricity
being produced at any one time and the amount
of electricity being consumed at any one time.
And you can get halfway decent estimates for
how much electricity is being consumed at
any one time. You can say, okay, well this
is baseline, how much people in businesses
use. And okay, there's a heat wave coming
up next week. So we can guess that people
are going to turn on their air conditioning
units and it'll increase a little bit. But
if you couple that with an unpredictable supply
from solar and wind, it becomes a very, very,
very tricky problem. And again, to emphasize
that I'm 100% in favor of expanding solar
and wind, we definitely need to expand that
as well, but we also need to figure out better
types of storage in order to be able to use
them properly.
SIERRA: And we re running out of time. Scientists
at the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change warn that the earth s average temperature
could hit the dangerous threshold of 1.5 degrees
warming by the early 2030s.
SIERRA: It's fascinating to me that we need
to expand nuclear, because it felt like when
I was growing up, nuclear energy was thought
of as something that was very bad for the
environment. And now it seems that the reverse
is true. There's still a little time left
just 10 years, according to some studies.
And this is a tool that we have that we know
works.
DEWAN: I think that's exactly right. I think
one of the more urgent pieces actually is
when it comes down to whether you want to
keep existing nuclear power plants open or
not, because there's a large number of about
99 operating in the US, about 440 worldwide,
of this older generation of conventional light
water reactors. And there've been a number
of places in the US where these plants have
been shut down, say, in New England where
I'm originally from. Then after the old nuclear
plants are shut down, the balance of electricity
production is made up for with coal power,
which is just catastrophic environmentally.
So I think it's really important also to not
shut down the existing facilities prematurely.
They're operating safely, they've been operating
safely for 30, 40, 50 years. And you want
to make sure that you keep reaping the benefit
of them. I think there is the potential for
people to start having warm feelings towards
the next generation of nuclear power plants.
And I think I'm not completely insane in saying
that, but they can say, "Okay, that is a carbon
free source of electricity. It's safe. It
is good for my community. I am glad that it's
part of the community." And that's my hope,
at least.
SIERRA: If you enjoyed this episode, head
over to CFR s Instagram, where I recently
had a live video chat with Leslie. While you
are there check out the other live chats we
have done with various guests from the show.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes. Have a question
or some feedback? Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we d love it if you
could leave us a review. Ideally a good one,
the more stars the better. It really does
help us get noticed. Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our associate podcast producer. Our intern
is Natalia Lopez. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Extra help for this episode was provided
by Claire Felter. Original music is composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks go to Richard
Haass and Jeff Reinke. For Why It Matters,
this is Gabrielle Sierra signing off. See
you soon!